I mean one of the most talented
filmmakers of uh you know my generation
is David Fincher but he's not in the
same category as me because I'm a writer
director and that makes it different
that makes it a different thing you know
and I think one of the things is one of
the things that I I've been focused on
is there's a lot of writer directors
that come out they write and direct one
movie a second movie a third movie well
there's a real voice there there's a
real voice but you know what it's hard
work to go to that blank piece of paper
and start from square ones start from
scratch every single solitary time you
are at the bottom of Mount Everest every
single solitary time and everything
you've done before not only does not
help you it could even like hang over
your head and that is a tough road to
hoe and you make less movies that way
and it's a lot easier to go and look at
the scripts that are out there and
available and you can maybe work with a
writer or do a little rewrite or do that
kind of thing and you get more movies
made but you know cut to six years down
the line and where's that voice it's
gone away